welcome to the Matt Walsh show everybody
remember to subscribe on iTunes or
become a premium member of The Daily
wire so you can get the whole show I've
got an idea just to just to begin things
with just kind of brainstorming here
what if we call unborn babies
undocumented and said instead of unborn
how about undocumented because maybe
then liberals will stop killing them do
you think you think that might work if
they're because when you think about it
it undocumented works for unborn
children much more than it works for
illegals these are babies who just have
not yet gotten the document of the birth
certificate just you know just something
to think about
speaking of undocumented babies
Democrats across the country are as
we've been talking about over the last
few days they are in a mad dash right
now to legalize late term abortion as
quickly as they can in as many states as
they can so it was already legal in six
states and also Washington DC
thanks to Democrats and now after last
week it's legal in New York as well and
then Virginia and Rhode Island have have
their own bills or had anyway
Virginia's bill has since been defeated
and Rhode Island's bill even if it
succeeds will not be able to do
everything that it intends to do because
it also will overturn the partial birth
abortion ban but partial birth abortion
which is an absolutely barbaric practice
of infanticide is illegal on the federal
level but the fact is even though the
one bill was shot down the other bill
even forward to succeed can't do
everything it could legalize late comer
abortion but not partial birth abortion
it still shows you it shows you where
the Democrat Party is right now and it
shows you what they want to do even if
they're not able to do everything that
they want to do and we learn everything
we need to know about the Democrat Party
based on their what has now become
mainstream support for late term
abortion which brings us to Governor
Northam in Virginia yesterday morning
North
was on a local radio station down there
in Virginia and he was asked about this
bill Northam is a Democrat now keep in
mind this guy we were was sold as a
moderate Democrat so this is supposed
this is what passes now for moderate
liberalism in the Democrat Party and
here's what this moderate Liberal
Democrat had the session there was a
very contentious committee hearing
yesterday when Fairfax County delegate
Cathy Tran made her case for lifting
restrictions on third trimester
abortions as well as other restrictions
now in place and she was pressed by a
Republican delegate about whether her
bill would permit an abortion even as a
woman is essentially dilating ready to
give birth and she answered that it
would permit an abortion at that stage
of labor
do you support her measure and explain
her answer yeah I'm you know I wasn't
there
Julie and I certainly can't speak for
delegate Tran but I will tell you one
first thing I would say this is why
decisions such as this should be made by
providers physicians and the mothers and
fathers that are involved there are you
know when we talk about third trimester
abortions these are done with the
consent of obviously the the mother with
the consent of the physicians more than
one physician by the way and it's done
in cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a fetus that's
non Bible so in this particular example
if a mother is in labor I can tell you
exactly what would happen the infant
would be delivered the infant would be
kept comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
but again we want the government not to
be involved in these types of decisions
we want the decision to be made by the
the mothers and their providers and and
this is why Julie that legislators most
of whom are men
by the way shouldn't be telling a woman
what she should and shouldn't be doing
with her body and do you think multiple
physicians should have to weigh in as is
currently required she's trying to lift
that requirement well I think it's
always good to get a second opinion and
for at least two providers to be
involved in that decision because these
decisions shouldn't be taken lightly and
and so that you know I would certainly
support more than one provider now so
yes he's he's advocating infanticide
we'll get to that in a minute but notice
notice how the interviewer does not
challenge him at all I mean you're an
interviewer and your interviewee is is
just proposed killing live infants and
we don't even get a wait what like we
don't even get that much I would I would
be happy just with that just one
follow-up of it doesn't even need to be
very specific just the follow-up could
be what so you want to kill infants
that's that's all the follow-up we don't
even get that she you see the expression
on her face she's just going with it
she's just nodding her head you know
she's doing this the whole time just
like yeah okay
no follow-up it's almost impressive at
this point how disgraceful the media
manages to be in every situation and
just like instinctively it's just
instinct just a visceral reaction now
they know they can go to the most
disgraceful reaction possible every
single time meanwhile if again if the
media had had any self-respect and if it
was at all interested in doing its job
then as this story was going viral
yesterday of the governor of Virginia
advocating infanticide every single
Democrat who has so far announced their
candidacy for 2020 would have been asked
by the media do you agree with governor
Northam about about killing infants
after they've been born they all would
have been asked just like every time
Donald Trump says anything that shocks
people every Republican every every
Republican on the national stage every
Republican who people care about that
they're all asked immediately
what do you think about this do you
agree with him but of course you don't
get that the same thing with with the
Democrats in fact forget about Northam
per minute and and his advocacy for
killing infants after they've been born
New York legalized late term abortion
last week it was a big story so every
single Democrat should have been asked
do you agree with this are you in favor
of killing babies in the third trimester
even though they could survive outside
of the womb and you could easily just
they have to be delivered anyway so you
could just hope you know they weren't
asked like hey you have a baby and in
the third trimester the mother wants to
end the pregnancy the baby has to come
out one way or another we could kill the
baby first and then take him out or we
could just take him out without killing
him do you think that it's okay to do
the first thing where you take that
extra step of killing the baby every
Democrat should be asked that question
but they're not asked in fact just to
give you an idea of how the national
media is covering this story let me read
a little bit from the Washington Post
article on this on the story about
Northam the posts the title the article
is failed abortion bill draws GOP
outrage against Virginia governor
Northam Democratic legislators so this
is the mean but it's true this is always
how it goes every time a Democrat says
anything or does anything outrageous and
horrible and disgusting the story for
the media is always Republicans pounced
Republicans are outraged conservatives
exploiting that's always that that's
always the story for them it's not the
thing that was said or done
it's how conservatives reacted to it so
they just we read a couple of paragraphs
from this article because it just shows
you so perfectly how our media deals
with with this issue it says President
Trump
Republican lawmakers in Virginia and
conservatives across the country
attacked governor Ralph Northam and
other state Democrats on Wednesday after
they defended a bill that sought to
reduce restrictions on late term
abortions so just as well stop right
there the first sentence is it's there
leading off right away it's with
Republicans attacking that's the story
right and this is how they summarize it
in the first paragraph it's it's not
that Republicans are attacking because
governor Northam advocated infanticide
it's because he defended a bill that
reduced restrictions on late term
abortions that's what we're gonna call
it now killing a baby after he has been
delivered is reducing restrictions on
late term abortions it goes on the furor
escalated quickly after Republicans
circulated a video of Delhi of delegate
Cathy Tran acknowledging that her bill
like current law would allow abortions
up to the point of delivery in cases
when the mother's life or health was at
serious risk let's stop right there
can we get a fact-checker on this
because I've found already we've got a
we've got a at least an extremely
misleading statement if not an outright
lie because they're saying the abortions
would the the law would allow abortions
in cases when the mother's life or
health was at serious risk well in this
exchange with Cathy Tran that they're
talking about she admits herself that
the serious risk to the mother's health
could be her mental health this could be
her mental health or emotional health
and Cathy Trend admits that in the
exchange that the Washington Post is
talking about right now but of course
the way that they present it now if you
didn't know any better you had no idea
about any of this you didn't know about
this exchange you hadn't seen it for
yourself you didn't know how these laws
worked and you read that statement you
would think cases where the mother's
life or health was at serious risk and
you're thinking physical health you're
thinking life-threatening situations but
that is not what the bill covers that's
not what it talks about and Cathy Tran
herself admitted that and anyway I don't
even need to go on you just you get do
you get the idea there now Northam of
course has since backtracked and claimed
that his comments were taken out of
context and he also went on Twitter
yesterday and made himself the victim
this is what he said on Twitter
he said I have devoted
my life to caring for children and any
insinuation otherwise is shameful and
disgusting yes we are the shameful and
disgusting ones you see it's us because
this poor guy look at this poor guy he
advocated for the Infanta for
infanticide and was prepared to sign a
bill that would condemn thousands of
babies to death but his hurt feelings
are really the problem here that's oh
this this this poor poor man that we
would dare be angry after he advocated
killing live babies outside of the womb
just so you know Northam we're not
insinuating anything
we are straight-up accusing you of of
advocating infanticide that's what we're
accusing you of not not insinuating
that's what we're saying because that's
what you said so all we're doing is
repeating what you said which was which
was itself horrible and disgusting and
that's what's happening here despite
what he's claiming now his comments are
very clear he's talking about a fanta
side in fact he talks about infanticide
in two forms he's he is advocating kind
of two methods or levels of infanticide
so and he goes through it very
methodically in the way that he explains
it and that's the only thing that was
kind of shocking about about what he
said is that it was so he was so clear
about it and usually Democrats it
doesn't surprise me to hear a Democrat
who has no problem with infanticide
that's all of these pro-abortion
Democrats they really have no problem
with it that's why with Kermit Gosnell
why do you think it was that that the
media ignored the Gosnell story and
never really expressed any real outrage
about it this was a guy in the middle of
a major American city for 30 years he
had been killing infants outside of the
womb chopping them up leaving body parts
strewn about in the refrigerator and
buckets on the side of the room either
the the the the clinic was and was in
shambles and not even sanitizing the
equipment ahead of time women were dying
an absolutely an absolute horror show
and Democrats didn't appear to be that
upset about it why is it why is that do
you think because they they have no
problem with it no matter what they say
when it comes down to it they really
don't have a problem they're fine it's
it's really fine with them if the baby
comes out and you kill the baby couple
seconds later you know because there's
really no difference in that and they're
right about that there really is no
difference kill the baby a couple
seconds before it comes out a couple
seconds after you know what's if I'm
okay obviously if I have gotten myself
to a place where I am so soulless and
such a psychopath that I'm okay with
killing a fully developed infant mere
moments before it comes out of the womb
then obviously I'm also gonna be okay
with killing the baby afterwards so
Democrats agree they've got they're fine
would they really are fine with this the
only thing that's unexpected is when
they come out and admit it so that's
what he did and here's what he talks
about he says the infant comes out of
the bit of the mother so now we're
dealing with an infant who was separated
from the mother no longer there's no
there's no more bodily autonomy this is
my body stuff that's all gone now you
never really had it was always gone
because that was never your body we were
talking about it's the body of a child
who is not you this is not your limb
okay but now that the child's out that
is all gone this is just a child and
what Northam is saying is that the
infant will be resuscitated
only if the mother wants if the mother
wants it we will resuscitate the infant
so they could just let the baby die
right there and that is infanticide
that's that's murder
and then he says even after the the
resuscitation there will be a discussion
okay the part about having a discussion
that's that's where he uses a little bit
more vague language so he can always
claim that it was taken out of context
even though it wasn't the first part is
not vague at all he's talking about
letting a baby die rather than
resuscitate it which as I said is murder
babies have to be resuscitated after
they're delivered all the time now
fortunately not in not in the majority
of cases of
where there's a birth but it's it's not
an it's not a complete it's not an
unheard-of thing that a baby will come
out and need some sort of immediate
medical attention
even resuscitation in more extreme sorts
of situations which is what the hospital
is there to do that's what doctors do
we're not talking about extreme measures
we're not talking about taking a baby
out and putting him on life support for
the next 15 years we're not talking
about we're just talking about he needs
immediate basic medical care do you give
it to him or not do you just put him
there on a table and let him watch him
die or do you do something basic to save
his life
what Northam is saying is you know maybe
you just put him on the table let him
die if that's what the mother wants just
let him die that's all which is morally
equivalent and identical in fact to if
you're sitting at the day at the dining
room table having dinner and your four
year old child starts choking to death
on a piece of broccoli and so you just
and someone tries to get up and to save
him and give him Heimlich or say no no
no no just sit there let's let this play
up and then you just sit there and watch
your child choke to death on broccoli
just sit there like this watching him
die exact same thing now any parent any
monstrous dirtbag who would do that in
the case of the of the four-year-old
child choking that person would go to
prison at the very least for
manslaughter if not for murder of some
degree so it's the exact same thing but
Northam doesn't stop there because he
says okay if the mother wants it you
resuscitated and then a discussion
ensues well he can always claim well I
just said discussion I didn't say what
they'd be talking about okay well what's
the discussion about Northam are they
gonna are they having a discussion about
about the football game last night are
they having a discussion about what
they're gonna name the child is that is
that what you meant by discussion no see
everyone knows and you know that what
you meant by discussion is it's going to
be a discussion about whether or not
they're going to kill that child because
that is you want it you're claiming it's
taken out of context the context of this
conversation
is abortion that's what we're talking
about is killing kids that was the
context of the discussion with the
interviewer so the discussion that
you're referring to is whether or not
we're going to kill the child in summary
the Democrat Party is overrun with
infanticidal bloodthirsty lunatics and I
don't say that as an insult
III I believe I agree with other people
who would say that we live in very
divided times and so we have to be
careful about the rhetoric we use and
it's very important to not use
overheated rhetoric and to not engage in
personal attacks personal insult and I
agree with that so when I say when I
call these Democrats bloodthirsty
infanticide old lunatics that's just a
description of what they are and it's
the most generous description I can
really come up with that's the best I
can do I'm being very generous with that
because to call them lunatics really
kind of lets them off the hook and I
believe in be in seeing the absolute
best in people I am an optimist do you
know that about me so I'm being very
optimistic when I say that all these
Democrats advocating infanticide and
late term abortion which is infanticide
itself as well I'm being very optimistic
when I say that they're just lunatics as
in they don't know any better when I
think we all actually know that that's
not even true that they're worse than
lunatics whatever whatever label you
want to put on it there's there's
there's no there's no happy label to put
on it this is a dark and disgusting
thing and we are at the point now where
the Democrat Party and you know the left
they have come they have long sense
abandoned any notion of safe legal and
rare that used to be the mantra safe
legal rare right and those Pro lifers
who had a little bit of foresight said
even then look you can't believe them on
that they don't really care about safe
and rare yeah they
want legal that's true but safe and rare
that's just it's just what they're
claiming it's not really what they want
and now we're at the point where yep
they have just punted on the rare part
of it they don't care about rare anymore
the people like to claim that slippery
slope arguments are fallacies but the
really incredible thing is that pretty
much every slippery slope argument that
conservatives have made about liberals
over the last 50 years have all come to
fruition they have all come true
all of them by the way the left
continues to to lie and claim that late
term abortions only happen in cases
where the woman's life is at risk and
I've already discussed this plenty and
I've explained why it's simply false it
is absurd late term abortion is never
necessary to save a woman's life ever it
may be necessary to end a pregnancy
early but you don't need to kill the
baby before you take it out but you
don't have to take it from me dr. Umar
Hamada had this to say on Facebook last
week he says I want to clear something
up so that there's absolutely no doubt I
am a board-certified OBGYN who has
delivered over 2,500 babies there is not
a single fetal or maternal condition
that requires third trimester abortion
not one delivery yes abortion no there
is absolutely no medical reason to kill
a near term or term infant for any
reason so there you go and guess who
agrees the Guttmacher Institute this is
a Research Institute that has radically
left radically pro-abortion this is the
Liberals use the GU mocker Institute all
the time to make whatever abortion
loving point they're trying to make well
goo marker has looked into this question
several times they've looked into it and
they have found that it is very very
very rarely the case that health is even
cited as a reason for a late term
abortion I think that they've said it
was it was
sited in like two or three percent of
all cases they did a report back in 2013
that goes into more details
let me read directly from the report
this it these are the results of the
Guttmacher Institute again a
pro-abortion Research Institute a
Research Institute that that Liberals
have already said is very credible they
use it all the time okay so this is what
goop mocker asked to say women aged 20
to 24 were more likely than those aged
25 to 34 to have a later abortion and
women and later abortion they're talking
twenty twenty weeks or later and women
who discovered their pregnancy before
eight weeks gestation were less likely
than others to do so later abortion
recipients experienced logistical delays
which compounded other delays in
receiving care most women seeking now
here's the part here's the important
part most women seeking later abortion
fit at least one of five profiles here
they are they were raising children
alone they were depressed or using
illicit substances they were in conflict
with a male partner or experiencing
domestic violence they had trouble
deciding and then had access problems or
they were young and Nellie nulliparous
now that last cat I don't know how to
pronounce that in the lip rest I think
it's how you pronounce it I had to look
that term up I confess I've never heard
that term before it apparently means
women who've never given birth before
and it could be they'd never given birth
because they just didn't want to give
birth or they had stillbirths
miscarriages in the past it does not
necessarily mean from what I read women
who currently have life-threatening
pregnancies okay so those are your five
categories in it's it's got nothing to
do with health saving the mother's life
according to the Guttmacher Institute
these are women who just made that it
basically these are lifestyle choices
they just for whatever reason they
didn't think it fit into their lifestyle
and why did they wait so long woman
because they had some logistical
problems or they just couldn't make up
their mind or things went bad in their
relationship whatever that that's why
they end up waiting this long so all
this stuff about well a woman's not just
going to go in there 28 weeks and get an
abortion
unless there's a serious medical problem
not the case that's the case according
to Goethe in a small small fraction of
instances all right moving on here's a
story I've been wanting to talk about
this for a few days but here's a story
that was in The Daily wire a few days
ago it says last week the Baltimore City
School Board unanimously decided against
allowing police officers to carry
firearms in public school legislation to
overturn the prohibition on firearms was
sponsored in the Maryland General
Assembly but then later withdraw and
because of the lack of support from the
City School Board the final vote was 10
to 0 the current law only permits the
roughly 90 Baltimore School City police
officers to carry their weapons when
school is not in session and requires
them to lock up the firearms while
inside schools and the article goes on
from there you can go read it on The
Daily wire to get more information about
this is this is just obviously total
madness that you won't allow police
officers to carry well first of all then
what are they there for and if you don't
trust your police officers with guns in
school then then what even is is the
point if there is any police officer on
the force right now in Baltimore City
who you don't trust with a gun around
kids then that's a guy that should not
be a police officer okay so that's an
easy way to solve that problem but if
you don't trust any of them with guns
then that means that you are just a
paranoid and delusional
there is no the idea that you gonna
disarm police officers and then send
them into the school is just okay and
then so then the school the school
shooter comes in what's the police
officer gonna do make himself a human
shield this is like this is like you
might as well pass a law saying that
when firefighters in Baltimore are
responding to a fire they have to leave
their hoses at home so
you're not allowed to bring any water
any hoses by the way you're not you
can't bring any access or anything
either because you might you might you
know the hose I mean you could if you
spray someone in the face you could hurt
them you could drown somebody if you
have an axe and you use it incorrectly
you might end up cutting someone's hand
off for goodness sake so yeah just run
in and deal with the fire but you know
figure out a way to do it maybe smother
the fire with your own bodies or
something absolute madness speaking of
madness there was an article in Arizona
Central which is a we're told part of
the USA Today Network and this is
someone who is someone wrote an
editorial who someone who has come up
with a very interesting reason to be
offended this is what it says it says a
few weeks ago this is written by Rashad
Thomas is the name of the opinion
contributor he says a few weeks ago I
attended a holiday party at a downtown
Phoenix restaurant I walked around to
view the photographs on the wall then a
photograph caught my attention friends
said it's coal miners at a pub after
work it was a photograph of coal miners
with blackened faces I asked a latinx
will taint rather than Latino latinx and
white woman for their opinion they said
it looked like coal miners out of pub
after work then they step back frowned
and said it's men in blackface I asked
the waitress to speak with a manager
instead I spoke with a white restaurant
owner I answered I may I explain to him
why the photograph was offensive
evidently someone else had made a
similar comment about the photograph
before yet the photograph remained on
the wall he said he would talk to the
other owners and get back to me while
leaving I asked him had he spoke with
the other owners he had not spoken with
them but mentioned Google said it's coal
miners after work who determines what's
offensive for me the coal miners
disappeared in a film honored for its
artistic merit despite being the most
racist propaganda films ever DW
Griffith's Birth of a Nation surfaces in
which white actors appeared in blackface
the white owner saw coal miners in the
photograph therefore it was not
offensive okay
first of all this is just a terribly
written
I know it's Arizona Central but still
you think they'd have better you think
they'd have higher standards this is
just a terribly written article but
that's beside the point I mean how many
times did he repeat in the first few
paragraphs
they said it's coal miners they said
it's coal miners we get it everyone
thinks it's coal miners except for you
so what you see here this is an example
it's hilarious which is one reason why
I'm pointing it out but you know the
first thing that jumps out at you is it
okay this is another overly sensitive
leftist who's looking for reasons to be
offended and who apparently lives his
life looking for reasons and this is
this is the this is the the food that
sustains him is finding outrage and
offense and that is yeah that's part of
it that's definitely part of the story
here the other part of the story though
is this is relativism and he says
themselves yeah everybody around me sees
that this is just coal miners after work
but I see it differently you know I draw
these crazy connections between this and
blackface and I remember the movie and
these and that and this and so that's
how I see it and I couldn't possibly be
wrong there's no way that I'm wrong so I
see it this way so how I see it must be
how it actually is my impressions must
therefore be legitimate because it's my
impression it's my opinion and if I find
it offensive
you see there's even this confusion you
can almost sense some confusion in his
voice like he can't understand well I
told everyone it offended me yet they
didn't take it down I don't understand
it well how could you not take it I I
said that it offended me what's the prob
where's the disconnect guys I just said
I'm offended by that and this is what
you get when you have someone who is our
people
let the leftist who are obsessed with
finding offense all the time and then at
the same time they're also relativists
who don't believe in objective truth
that's how you end up with a situation
like this where they're just finding a
fence
everywhere they go finally let's quickly
check few emails you can email the show
at Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
from Ryan he says hi Matt I've noticed
that you you have tattoos two questions
what are they also how do you justify
tattoos given that the Bible prohibits
them I've gotten an email like this
about 15 times this week so I figured I
might as well just answer it I have I do
have two tattoos that's one that's
called a Cairo which is a Cristo Graham
formed from the first two letters of
Christ in Greek it's a very ancient
Christian symbol used by Constantine I
like it because of its ancient tradition
also it's got kind of a militant flavor
and history to it and I think that
Christianity needs that sort of militant
spirit a warrior spirit especially in
these times that's why I like I'd also
have a a Celtic Anchor cross right here
with the phrase salvation from the cross
in Latin which is the first tattoo I got
as far as how I justify it well
fortunately I'm not bound by the
ceremonial laws of the Old Testament
especially a law that was given in the
case of tattoos to prohibit people from
tattooing pagan symbols on themselves or
to preventing them from tattooing as
part of the pagan ritual so this is not
a pagan ritual it's not a pagan symbol
and those laws don't buy this anymore
moral laws do but not the ceremonial law
so the the prohibitions on tattoos that
goes in the same camp as don't wear
mixed fiber don't don't eat pork and all
that kind of stuff so it's pretty easy
for me to see the distinction there but
just because it's we're not bound by
that prohibition that doesn't mean that
it's necessarily advisable to go and get
a tattoo that's up to personal
preferences and and my preference was to
get one so that's that's all if someone
doesn't like tattoos that's that's
perfectly fine but this is the one thing
that kind of frustrates me there are
some Christians say well you can't get
tattoos you can't drink and all this
kind of stuff and that's fine again if
that's your personal preference if
that's how you choose to live perfectly
fine that's great that's also good for
you I respect it but Christianity itself
does not actually require that
Christianity is not actually a
puritanical religion
Christianity has the impression of being
very close-minded very narrow very
restrictive and it is closed off from
sin closed off from falsehood it does
have in effect what we would call all
restrictions but it is not how it is
painted as this just boring bland thing
in fact Christianity is is allows for
all different types of approaches and
and opinions and everything and if you
want to drink and be merry if you want
to get a tattoo go ahead you can't you
can do that if your conscience tells you
not to then don't
let's see James says under the green New
Deal the federal government would
control all energy production and with
medicare-for-all it would control all
access to health care in your eyes is
there anything tyrannical about a
government that has this much power
what about unconstitutional what will be
next total takeover of education making
public school mandatory love the show
thanks James my answer is yes yes and
yes the left is trying to move us to a
place where the government controls
literally everything yes of course it is
tyranny it would also be the end of the
United States and the end of the
American dream and the failure of the
American experiment if our country falls
into tyranny less than 300 years after
it was founded which is the blink of an
eye in the grand scheme of things and
there are countries around today they've
been around for thousands of years we
won't we've got less than 300 years
which is just we're still basically well
maybe not in our infancy as a nation but
we're in our adolescence at most as a
nation if at this point you know the
left completely takes over and
everything is taken over by the
government we have no more freedom or
Liberty then then that means America
just failed it was a wonderful and
beautiful experiment which was great
while it lasted but it was a failed
experiment in that case and so that's
that's what we're fighting for it just
puts it into context what we're fighting
for though again I think it's worth
noting that the irony here that leftist
they want the government to control
everything even while insisting that
Donald Trump is Hitler and for some
reason they don't see the problem
they're right fine
from Jess she says hi Matt what's your
take on Howard Schultz being asked about
the price of Cheerios thank you for
bringing that up Jess yes Howard Schultz
the billionaire former CEO of Starbucks
running for president or consider
running for president as an independent
is not popular with the left LA the left
hates the guy they hate him because they
think that he's gonna steal votes you
know he's going to siphon off moderate
liberal voters thus reelecting Trump
they also hate him because he's a
billionaire this is a guy who came up
from nothing he apparently I learned
this yesterday apparently he lived as a
kid in a housing project and that
eventually he opens a little tiny coffee
shop in Seattle and he builds that into
an empire and becomes a billionaire this
this is the American dream this is not
someone who inherited millions from his
family who was born into wealth and
success this is really a rags to riches
story and if we're at a point in our
country where we can't admire and
respect that then I don't know what's
left I don't even know what we're doing
anymore so he goes on Morning Joe and
they ask him if he knows about you know
how much the buy a box of Cheerios costs
which is such a stupid gotcha question
obviously the reason he's being asked is
they're trying to paint him as out of
touch now keep in mind so the media is
they're focused on whether or not Howard
Schultz knows the price of a box of
brand-name cereal even while the
governor of Virginia is advocating
infanticide so you've got the governor
of juvy genius saying let's kill babies
out of the womb the media ignores that
and they're and they're saying well what
about Howard Schultz he doesn't know how
much Cheerios cost but who cares you
know what I don't know how much a box of
Cheerios costs I have no idea and it's
not big I'm not a billionaire it's
because it's for a few reasons number
one I don't eat Cheerios because because
I'm a grown-up number two I'm a man and
as a man even though I've gone grocery
shopping plenty of times I really I have
no idea how much anything cost so box of
Cheerios
like if you
tell me about some Cheerios cost four
dollars I would believe you if you told
me it costs fifteen I'd believe you
there - I have no idea when I go grocery
shopping I just I walk down the aisle I
just pick things out based on sight it's
just it's really more of a based on gut
instinct type of thing and also based on
just how hungry I am and then and then I
go and I take it to the checkout and I'm
always surprised by what the price is so
it's kind of a fun game so that's all it
means absolutely nothing and if if
Howard Schultz doesn't know how much
Cheerios cost because he's eating you
know a fancy Eggs Benedict breakfast
prepared by his personal chef every
morning then you know what good for him
that's awesome I wish I had a personal
chef making me pregnant if I could
afford a personal chef making me
breakfast every morning I would
definitely pay for one that would be
great so good for him all right we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed